ولا شك مشاهدينا ان الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا لعب دورا كبيرا في تمكينها من
الصمود في ساحه المعركه كميات كبيره من
الاسلحه تدفقت وحزم ماليه ضخمه تم ضخها في
ميزانيه كييف لكن في الوقت نفسه فان
الكثير من المساعدات الماليه لاوكرانيا لم
تصل بعد الخبر كشفت عنه صحيفه الامريكيه
التي اشارت الى ان نصف المساعدات التي
وعدت بها الدول الغربيه لاوكرانيا لم تصل
بعد وقدرت الصحيفه قيمته هذه المساعدات
بنحو 35 مليار دولار الصحيفه نقلت ايضا
تصريحا لتيموفي ميلو فانوس المستشار
الاقتصادي في اداره الرئيس الاوكراني
والذي اكد وجود مشكله في مدفوعات
المساعدات حيث انها
متقلبه ومتاخره وغير مستقره
حزم ماليه كثيره اذا تعهد حلفاء اوكرانيا
بدفعها من بينهم الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي
بدا في البحث عن اصلاحات لتنظيم عمليه
تحويل المساعدات الى كييف واتخذ الاتحاد
الاوروبي الاجراءات لضمان استقرار عمليه
الدفع لاوكرانيا كما وعد بمساعده ماليه
منتظمه تصل الى اكثر من 19 مليار دولار
خلال العام الجاري بمعدل ما يقارب 1.6
مليار دولار شهريا ويرجع سبب تضاؤل
التحويلات مساعدات الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
حزم الدعم التي تم الاعلان عنها للتعامل
مع المشكله في الاقتصاديه الداخليه من
ازمات الطاقه والتضخم وغيرها